>>Class: I am a Concourse Village
Scholar, destined for success!
Educated by the best teachers on earth!
>>Alexa: What we're doing at our school
is we're all working toward the same
goal, we're all speaking
the same language.
We're able to have common
conversations across all grade levels,
so that it doesn't matter what
class your child ends up in,
every parent can rest assured knowing
that their child is receiving
a high quality education.
>>Class: My achievements will leave
a lasting impression on the world.
[ sound of school bus ]
>>Alexa: Concourse Village Elementary
School is located in the South Bronx,
and we are categorized as the poorest
congressional district in the nation.
However, by visiting our school,
you would never think that,
and that's something
that I'm really proud of.
When I was a teacher, it was about who
was the best teacher in the building.
And every year the children
needed to re-learn a new system,
a new language, a new structure.
And it didn't benefit them in any way.
I wanted to create a school
where teachers felt community,
where everyone knew the children,
where we felt like a family,
and where systems were in place
for everyone to be successful,
not just the students,
but also the teachers.
>>Teacher: Good morning!
>>Student: Good morning!
>>Alexa: In 2013, I walked
into a situation
where the school that
existed was being phased out.
So I did inherit the children
from the phase-out school,
and there was a major deficit
across all content areas.
>>Teacher: Okay, so what
does increase mean?
>>Alexa: We looked at
the reading levels,
and we saw that they had a low
literacy rate, and research said
if they're not reading on or
above level by third grade,
the likelihood of them ending
up in prison increases.
>>Teacher: Two, one, begin!
[ class begins Collaborative Reading ]
>>Alexa: So the first
year was very challenging.
We trying to come up with a plan, and
see, "Okay, how are going to make sure
that all the children are reading on
grade level, so that they're prepared?"
>>Student: Thoughtful readers...
>>Class: Thoughtful readers...
>>Student: ...summarize what
they learned from the text.
>>Class: ...summarize what
>>Alexa: When I was a reading
specialist, I did a lot of research
on reading programs and
what really worked.
Immediately, Collaborative Reading was
a tool that I brought into the school,
because I knew that it
would align us across grades
and support creating great readers.
>>Class: Pete the cat was walking down
the street in his new white shoes.
>>Alexa: Initially, a lot of people
did not understand the concept
of Collaborative Reading.
So ensuring that all teachers
have professional development
and understood the research
behind it was vital.
>>Teacher: So the first thing
that we do is to make sure
that we know what the
question is asking, right?
>>Alexa: Once the teachers
started to see the progress,
and as soon as reading levels started to
spike up and our children were starting
to feel really proud and
confident, they were onboard.
Today, we infuse literacy at all costs,
at all times, in all content areas.
So you'll see literacy in art.
>>Teacher: What would it feel like
to be on the street in this collage?
Provide evidence from
the work to support.
>>Alexa: In math, you will see children
engaging in the 3-Read Protocol.
>>Student: The gist of the story was
each round they get a certain amount
of points.
>>Alexa: And they'll use the
Problem-Solving Procedure
to annotate text.
>>Teacher: So do we agree
with her so far?
>>Alexa: Another great practice
that is implemented schoolwide
are the Participation Cards.
>>Teacher: Remember to use
your Participation Cards
to agree or disagree with Owen.
>>Alexa: These practices
that are consistent staples are
what allows us to create success.
Regardless of what grade
the child is in,
and how they progress
throughout the school,
the child still has the
same consistency.
When the situations are predictable,
the children feel a lot
safer, and so do the teachers.
>>Alexa: So have a great weekend!
>>Alexa: We have a model
that we're a community
of one, and no doors are closed.
No one is an island here.
And we're sharing best
practices because we want
to be the best we can
be for our children.